p les 35 heures feront l'objet d'un
véritable réaménagement
l'assouplissement est inscrit dans les
projets du gouvernement et françois
fillon présentait aujourd'hui au
syndicales les premières grande débauche
qui apporte un certain nombre de
modifications sur le régime des heures
supplémentaires les syndicats se disent
déçus le projet sera examiné par
l'assemblée au début du mois prochain
françois beaudonnet de tente de nous en
tracer les grandes lignes
augmenter le nombre d'heures
supplémentaires et diminuer le repos
compensateur sans que cela coûte trop
cher aux entreprises voilà l'objectif
affiché par le gouvernement raffarin dès
le mois d'octobre un décret va faire
face ils plafond d'heures
supplémentaires de 130 à 180 heures par
an vous pouvez travailler 39 heures par
semaine en moyenne dont quatre en heures
supplémentaires ce contingent d'heures
pourra même être augmenté si les
partenaires sociaux signent un accord de
branche pour le paiement des heures
supplémentaires si vous êtes dans une
entreprise de moins de 20 personnes les
quatre première heures seront payés 10%
de plus qu'une heure normale dans les
autres entreprises ce taux serait
compris entre 10 et 25% et ce sera à la
négociation entre patrons et syndicats
de le déterminer enfin le paiement sous
forme de repos pour les quatre premières
heures et supprimer jusqu'à présent au
contraire il était obligatoire ces
heures seront donc tout simplement
rémunérés